it is something that is endemic Mark
it's something that people have grown up
being accustomed to
this is a problem that has started many
many years ago and people are just now
thinking that it's a norm that when they
say certain things they may think it's
funny they may think oh I've heard it so
many times the amazing because they have
grown up in a society that has accepted
that it has a norm that it is okay
that has to change
what what people need to recognize Mark
is that not everyone who says something
that may be deemed racist or behaves not
racist manner is a bad person they have
said it or done it because that's what
they are accustomed to seeing and living
around them my problem though is with
those who then get to realize that they
are making bad decisions with things
that they say and do and recognize that
yes it's not what I should be doing
don't change